hello everyone how are you guys all
doing hope you guys are having a
wonderful day and today as you can see
we are here at the grand exchange what
are we going to be doing well from the
title and you know presumptively if you
guys know a thing or two about the game
we are going to be doing these series
worthless to Wall Street
and I know I know I just needed I need
something kinda catchy as far as title
goes I don't know that's what that's
what I thought of I thought it was
pretty decent so basically the
guidelines we're gonna start with five
mill trust me I have I had five mill to
start I'm recording this afterwards but
we have we have some money in the GE
currently hopefully nothing pops up
showing you guys what I'm currently
doing
you might have a might have a guest then
it's how much money I have nonetheless
so this gonna be kind of probably like
two to three times a week uploaded
series I'd like to get around there so
um pretty much we're going to start with
five mill we're gonna merge random
things until we can get to wherever I
want to go with this account this is
pretty much just my merge account as you
can see we're not doing anything other
than merging on this account we're just
gonna stay here at the GE we might be
charging fair acceptors sometimes once I
get more money that is something you can
do with literally no stats at all
literally nothing's necessary so I feel
like doing that's okay and counts kind
of as merging so nonetheless we're going
to get right on into I hope you guys
enjoy the series if you guys do and if
you guys want to see more feel free to
leave a sub then you'll be alerted as
soon as I go live in the future not as
soon as I go live sorry twitch man
twitch um as soon as my videos get
posted so nonetheless if you guys want
to feel free sub if you guys enjoy the
video leave a like if there's anything I
can improve on comment down below
nonetheless we're going to get right on
into it right now alright so we're going
to get right on into it let's check out
I don't know I kinda wanna do a like the
best way to merch is to keep all of your
money working at the same time so you
don't want to stock pilots too much into
buying future stuff but real quick
dragon boots have gone up a ton so I'm
going to check out if there's any marge
on these so 218 probably not cuz it's
hovering around the mid price but yeah
800 GP margin every now and then you'll
get like a a 3 to 4 K margin on those
and those are insane alright so we have
all of the items that we're going to do
the same right d Hyde is going to get us
probably about
a 25k margin I believe corals bows like
10 a meal or et's 10 and then you seeds
are 5 you seeds a buy and sell a lot
quicker than anything else so we'll
actually probably be making the most
amount of money off of the you seeds
assuming we don't get undercut we could
get undercut because I just want to cut
someone else but hopefully we can we can
find a middle ground with this so there
we go four of these bows have now bought
so I'm gonna list them up for whatever
it says here 1 6 foot 2 500 so we made a
cool I don't know 28 K is not even that
much but you take we can get all right
so all my you seeds have butts now we're
just gonna throw man for let's just say
71 900 because they were not selling at
all for 72 K so hopefully they sell for
that and then we will make about I don't
know over 100 K on all that so that's
good now the grills Bo's are sharing to
sell as well so profits flowin all right
so now all of the grills Bo's have sold
so we're gonna buy some more also we've
bought and sold already one the same
Rock T had we're gonna sell another so
here we go as you can see some of my
stuff did sell so and some stuff did buy
so let's just check this out real quick
all of these AM EDI tops sold the
Kirill's crossbows bought these glories
aren't going to sell at all it doesn't
seem like so I'm just gonna take all
those away I'm going to find the sell
prices at both of these sell them all
off and then we'll try to find something
else here in a second all right there we
go ahead to up the price but all that
you chomp is bought so I just got two K
of them for 164 - I'm going to try to
sell them for 1 6 8 - and then I'll make
a quick 80k there we go so we are we
just sold the mm wrench and chompers I'm
going to see the new margin on him and I
might just stick on these items this
team battle staff actually has a 20k
margin but I don't know that was in
there for about an hour I gotta sell
these two things I got to get it out of
here
alright so then we're going to take this
nice and easy buy another batch of Qin's
and see if we can make a little profit
off of these as well I want to go
probably until I hit my limit there
could be other things I could put my
money into but realistically these buy
and sell pretty much in bulk so it's not
that bad of a idea my bad brother coin
okay
alright so there we got reg into but
again so I'm going to buy another one to
see what they buy for so maybe I could
just put it up for this price or I might
put a little over so it is currently 165
oh I'm gonna try to put them in for 167
oh and then we'll make about a little
over 100k on that in total there we go
look at that 167 oh I bought them all
for a collective let's look at it four
point two three mil and I sold them all
for four point three four so I made
about 100 15k is off of that I really
don't know what else I'd like to do just
because I come in and out so these
things are killing it right now for me
I'm gonna check out another one and just
[__] keep on doing this [__] one six
seven three and the like that actively
trade is one six one three just give me
a second on these red chins I'm just
going to throw in an offer at the met
price for [__] 2.7 K worth of them or
something like that yeah 2.7 K and then
hopefully we can do something with that
alright and literally within five
minutes all the red Chin's have bought
so we will list them up for what they
were originally by four so one six eight
six and then we'll see what kind of
profit we're going to make on that one
six eight six put that in for point four
one three and we bought them all four
four point three one seven so we permit
just made a quick hundred K that will
literally be bought and sold in less
than probably five to ten minutes right
so at this point the red Chin's have
kind of dropped a little bit I'm still
making money on them but I'm making 3gp
off of each [__] one so I'm gonna
make 10 K that's you know nothing be
excited about but it's what I got to do
I've tried to sell them for the last
half an hour while I'm just been like
making breakfast and [__] and they
aren't selling so I got to get rid of
them the you see that actually are
selling now so we got something there
alright so everything is sold let's grab
it all out we're up to five point four
mill so we're gonna find a couple items
and then we'll be good to go all right
so it's only a matter of time but
actually put an offer for some more
cannonballs then since I was already
bought you know just up at a GP put in a
thousand there we go alright so we'll be
back in a second once these things have
bought and sold hopefully all right so
just died on my main trying to do some
sire anyways all of these mahogany
planks have sold as you can
as you can see a couple of them actually
did sell but I am gonna try to list them
up for a little under what they were
selling for just so I can get some
profit out of it while everything else
has seemed you pretty much come to a
halt I can imagine why the cannonballs
have because I'm pretty sure I've
reached my limit on those so let me just
throw these in real quick and then we'll
wait for those to sell maybe they'll
instant sell I don't know but anyways
the gilded plate bodies actually are you
know doing well doing well so I'm gonna
keep rolling on with these making good
40k each time I buy and so on and we'll
just uh we can do what we can with these
we good we good they got it they done so
uh we do have two gilda plate bodies I
just bought I think they just both
bought at the same time which is kind of
weird I also found out that there was a
pretty good margin on adamant darts
there's like a seven to eight you my
[__] god 7 8 GB margin I'm gonna in
this clip soon [__] camera and sell
these template bodies alright so
everything else seems to be screwing me
over for the most part none of this
stuff is selling granted I mean I'll
find a price for to sell probably around
where I bought it but the Gillett play
bodies still still holding strong so
we'll stick with these I they and I
thought it would never happen but some
of the school actually started to sell
no way alright there we go so we got the
gilded body or the gilded leg set too
soon I'm gonna try to buy it a little
above what the guide price is so should
I actually try to buy it for a little
over that I mean I would still make
about 130 K for each one of these flips
so I'll just put an offer for that and
we'll give it some time and so here's
where they profits are coming so there
we go
gilded and plate set for 436 K
apparently I could've bought it for a
lot less now that I look at the the
current guide price but uh nonetheless
hopefully we can sell it for that and
then I will you know lower my next buy
price there we go literally with in
probably three minutes or so that was
able to sell so we're gonna buy another
one and um just kind of do the same
thing so we did see a second ago that
this will probably be the good goodbye
price and then we'll be able to make
200k off of each one so let's give
sometime again literally within minutes
another one has bought so I think these
might actually just be getting a lot of
attention because of the recent update
to free-to-play this is like the only
way they play yeah like you can actually
use this in free-to-play so I feel like
it's just getting a lot more attention
from free-to-play people currently I'm
getting you know I just got tele block
in my main so we'll switch over to that
if you guys want to see that look at
this man just trying to kill Ben and on
it's just hanging out got tea bead we
will just will just try to tank it
should I run north you think I mean
running it doesn't make sense to run
anyway but they're kind of like blocking
me from that way so yeah we'll run north
why not screw it right yeah oh yeah bad
idea
I don't even know what I what I could do
in the situation all's I have to do is
just know to keep my prior up oh man
this is this is a blast yeah yeah good
job good job you got some antidotes man
hope you're happy with that there
anyways back over the merge so as you
can see we're about to sell this on now
for a cool 200k profit once it sells
I'll be pretty I will live hit 6 mil so
I'll probably do a couple more of these
merchants for this episode and that'll
probably be over I don't know how much I
want to aim for 4 yup so I'm thinking
about a mil for the beginning once but
uh you guys have any suggestions feel
free to leave them in the comments down
below and there we go you guys can hear
that that you will be away for final in
the background anyways gilded set has
sold I'm gonna buy another one obviously
about the same price we'll see if the
guide price gone down a little bit and
has not but we will put it in for no not
should we do that yeah probably
alright let's go with that alright so we
were just able to get the gilded leg set
gonna go back and see like can resell it
for currently and hopefully that will
sell overnight so I guess well I guess
we'll find out alright so it seems as if
that if I buy all of these for their
lowest price I should be buying the set
itself for about 4 point 1 mil
and then if you go to the guilded you go
to the gilded set and look at the
actively traded price you'll get four
point four five mil so assuming I'm able
to buy one of all of those I should be
able to make about 300k just off of you
know making into a set which is insane I
think this is what we're going to do I
got a whole set buying and then I also
have two gilded full homes on the side
buying because I want to put a little
bit of my money towards something so
hopefully we can get this all to buy and
then we should be good
all right so all these just bought in
quick succession
however the gilded plate legs did not
buy okay insta bought for literally 10k
more than I was you know that then I had
my offer in force so that's perfectly
fine with me so let's go over to sets
and then we're going to throw all these
together I don't know the exact price at
which this is going to sell out but I'm
just going to follow the actively traded
price because that means something has
bought or sold around that price so
we're going to go for four for some 5k
and we will hopefully sell that here
sand there we go so we got this actually
to sell for four point four seven five
which means we made a pretty decent
amount off of that so let's just take
out this cash and we'll see what we're
totally at so six point four to one so
we're gonna try to do that just the way
we did but I do it again I guess alright
just like to start off by saying I'm
[__] liar when I said in the last
clip I was going to do a couple more of
these that will be for the next video
this videos already been dragging on too
long so nonetheless hope you guys
enjoyed if you did feel free to leave a
like if you want to see more drop sub
you'll be informed as soon as my videos
go up in the future and if there's
anything I can improve upon feel free to
leave it in the comments down below I
know a lot of you are new because I'm
kind of a new youtuber and most of you
are coming for my guides hopefully those
helped you hopefully you guys have a
great day and peace the next merging
video should be up in about two to three
days out imagine so hopefully you guys
get to see that nonetheless hope you
guys have a great day and B's